i'm back
oh my hair really you ruined my
groove i'm gonna do that again
hello reject nation my name is sally sally
lamonico aka salamander if you're an og you
might remember me on the channel from many many
moons ago if not hello i was just talking to greg
and revealed a deep dark secret to him that i
actually have not seen most of the mcu movies
i know i know it's horrible but for once
my procrastination has paid off because
i came up with a great i well we came up with
i came up with a great idea that we would
watch the marvel movies together on this
channel phases one through four so i have
seen many of them but i saw them like right
when they came out and to be honest i don't
really remember plot very well from a lot of these
movies and i don't really remember many details i
remember enjoying them i just didn't retain a lot
of that information i'm going to rewatch the ones
that i have seen and then you'll be able to see
my fresh reactions seeing them for the second
time and then seeing a lot of them for the first
time i've not seen endgame i've not seen infinity
war can't wait to watch those with you guys but
we're going to go in order that way it's the full
dramatic effect so it's going to be a great
time please hit that notification bell
if you want to be up to date on when i'm going
to be posting i am planning on posting on this
channel once a week and we are going to go through
all of them until the very end also if you enjoyed
this video if i make you laugh if you like
looking at me i don't know please give a like
on the video because it does help the algorithm
and helps keep this channel alive also obviously
this video is edited this is not the full reaction
to the full movie if you want to watch the movie
with me completely unedited sit down grab a bull
popcorn and see my full reaction to everything you
can watch the full reaction on the real rejects
patreon just go to patreon.com the real rejects so
check it out lastly thanks to prepper for editing
together these highlights for the channel y'all
are a real one if i say anything embarrassing
please cut it out i'm going to be calling this
segment the marvel movie marathon say that five
times fast marvel movie marathon marvel movies
sally sells seashells by the seashore see i
can say that one for the first mcu movie we
are watching together we are starting off
with a bang iron man let phase one begin
i feel like you're driving in a court martial this
is crazy what did i do hey forest we can talk sir
oh i see so it's personal no you intimidate them
good god you're a woman i mean i'd apologize but
isn't that what we're going for here i thought
i'd use a soldier first i'm an airman but you
have actually excellent bone structure there
i'm kind of having a hard time not looking at
you now is that weird he got me flustered if
i take a picture with you yes it's very cool
i don't want to see this on your myspace page
please no gang signs oh that dates this myspace
dude i would down that whiskey
that is starting out way darker than i thought
it would today tony stark has changed the face
of the weapons industry by ensuring freedom
and protecting america and her interests
around the globe is he supposed to
be like a hotter version of elon musk
ladies and gentlemen it is my honor to present
this year's apogee award to mr tony stark
tell me you get shot tony it's
okay well i'm not tony stark
but if i were tony i would
tell you how honored i feel
render on to caesar that
which is caesar's there you go
do you plan to report on the millions we've
saved by advancing medical technology or kept
from starvation with our intellicrops all
those breakthroughs military funding honey
you ever lose an hour sleep your whole
life be prepared to lose a few with you
this is a disney movie
is that malibu looks like malibu
yes let's go it's malibu represent after all
these years tony still has you picking up
the dry cleaning i do anything and
everything that mr shark requires
including occasionally taking
out the trash will that be all
yo
shots fired the mit commencement is in june please
don't harangue about this stuff they're harassing
you so i'm gonna say yes deflect and absorb it
don't i need you to sign this before what are
you trying to get rid of before we got plans
for you as a matter of fact they do i don't
like it when you're up oh he's jealous come on
get yourself something nice for me i already
did and oh it was very nice very tasteful
thank you mr stark your welcome responsible
that sexual tension is great it
would be irresponsible not to
drink i'm just talking about a nightcap hot sake
yes too please no just i'm not drinking i
don't want any if that's what i'm talking
yes
for your consideration the jericho
i'll be throwing one of these in with
every purchase of 500 million or more
it's a piece oh nice
ah that is an electromagnet
hooked up to a car battery and it's keeping
the shrapnel from entering your heart
ah let me that makes you feel uncomfy it says
for you to start working immediately and
when you're done it will set you free
yeah right yeah that's palladium 0.15 grams
we need at least 1.6 i wanted to go break
down the other 11. careful careful we only
got one shot of this i have steady hands
why do you think you're still alive huh yeah how
do you not get anxious building a bomb in a cave
a suit the iron giant wrong movie
he's like that's not a bomb
jericho
i'm surprised i don't have any of the other
guys like actually in the room with him
but i guess that would defeat this whole purpose
he's speaking hungarian i don't
speak hungarian okay what do you know
open it i dare you
they're coming
he's gonna die isn't he
surprise
that must be heavy
oh that would hurt so bad
oh that sound
watch out
how do you miss he's like right there
my turn
yeah
everything's gonna explode what are you doing
what an idiot
yeah let's shoot at explosives
it's gotta be like cooking
him how is he not burning
happy fourth of july
not bad
imagine they just flew by
she was worried take us to the hospital no he's
happy no tony no you have to go to the hospital
captivity for three months three months
effective immediately i am shutting down
the weapons manufacturer division international
as i can decide what the future of this company
will be what direction it should take one that
i'm comfortable with and is consistent with the
highest good for this country as well good for him
we're a team do you understand there's nothing we
can't do if we stick together like your father and
i i'm sorry i didn't give you a heads up okay
but if i had tony we can't eat no more then you
would have said no so just gently lift okay
okay uh i don't think that i'm qualified to
do this you're fine you are the most capable
qualified trustworthy person i've ever met
should she be putting her ring
in there it smells yeah it does
the copper wire the copper where you got it i got
it okay you got it they didn't need to add sound
effects okay now make sure that when you pull
it out you don't pull out that doesn't matter
at the end of it that was it what's wrong uh
not that i'm just going into cardiac arrest
because you yank i thought you said this
was safe we gotta hurry take this take this
he's so calm it's gonna be okay okay put
it in stop talking he's dying like shut up
are you okay yeah i feel great you okay
he's gonna have to get her therapy ever ever
ever ask me to do anything like
that ever again i don't have anyone
that made me emotional
of course he didn't die
that was good framing i
liked that and three two one
that's so cool for lack of a better option dummy
is still on fire safety if you douse me again
and i'm not on fire i'm donating you
to city college all right nice and easy
seriously don't do it in the room with
your nice cars bro in three two one
okay please don't follow me
around with it either because
i feel like i'm gonna catch on fire spontaneous
okay this is where i don't want to be
jarvis you there that's your
service uh engage heads-up display
check record all preferences from home interface
we'll do so that's sick i love the silver
imagine like
going in the water and then drowning in
that thing oh my god my anxiety could never
you're crazy oh my god
uh
kill power
i knew a car would get destroyed at some point
it's kind of insulting but also is sweet connect
to the cisco have it reconfigure the shell metals
use the gold titanium alloy from the sarah from
tactical satellite that should ensure fuselage
integrity while maintaining power to weight
ratio got it yes got it understood all of that
some claim he's suffering from post-traumatic
stress and has been bedridden for weeks whatever
the case may be no one expects an appearance
from him tonight oh is he just gonna like pull up
love that hey tony you remember
me sure don't oh my god
stanley yeah what's the world coming to him you
guys got to crash oh my god look at you geez
hey what a surprise surprise [__] you look
fantastic i didn't recognize you what are you
doing here she's avoiding government are you by
yourself would you get that dress i oh it was a
birthday present from you actually martini's extra
dry extra olives extra fast make one of them dirty
did he put 100 in there i don't know
oh hey thanks see you here yikes
can i at least get a reaction from you panic
i actually almost fought at hook line and
sinker i was out of town for a couple months
in case you didn't is this
what you call accountability
if we're double dealing under the table are we
silence is an answer guys always remember that
recent violence has been attributed to a group
of foreign fighters referred to by locals as the
ten rings either forced to join their militia
he's like ah i can blow people up yes
cover their eyes
nice
he's all yours
well i need your help right now it's funny how
that works huh yeah speaking of funny we've got
a weapons depot that was just blown up a few
clicks from where you were being held you sure
you don't have any tech in that area i should
know about nope this isn't a game you do not send
civilian equipment into my active war zone you
understand that this is not a piece of equipment
he's a superhero be gentle it's my first
time i designed this to come off so hey
what's going on here
let's face it this is not the worst thing
you've got me doing are those bullet holes
of course this is only a first crude effort a
man with a dozen of these can rule all of asia
i will give you these designs as a gift i hope
you'll repay me with a gift of iron soldiers
come on don't worry it'll only last for
15 minutes all right let's finish up here
it's just weird seeing jeff bridges as a
villain i keep thinking of the big lebowski
sector 16.
she figured it out oh hey dude the dude is here
to kill i know what you're going through pepper
like literally or metaphorically
you are a very rare woman
tony doesn't know how lucky he
is creep better get back there
that was stressful tony stark was able to
build this in a cave with a box of scraps
i'm not tony stark
oh no ah tony when i uh ordered a hit on
you i'm worried that i was
here comes the villain speech
killing the golden goose no no no okay where's
tony now i don't know he's not answering his phone
please go over there and
make sure everything's okay
didn't he say it lasted like 15 minutes
how is he walking how is he alive
she's fine she's with five agents
they're about to rest over that
that's not gonna be enough my key's
not working it's not opening the door
oh wow what's that it's like a little device
it's like a thing that's gonna pick the lock
that's the coolest thing i've
ever seen not bad huh let's do it
damn
of course she's in heels ah how are
you running with heels on the grated
floor oh my god pepper tony tony are you
okay i'm fine oh but he's he's got insane
what the
girl you better keep running in those hills
oh my god
it's like transformers for 30 years
he's gonna freeze them
my suit is more advanced in every way how'd
you solve the icing problem icing problem
you might want to look into it we are
now running on emergency backup power
are you okay i'm almost out of
power i gotta get out of this thing
i'll be right there how did you not die oh my god
oh
this looks important
i never had a taste for this
sort of thing but i must admit
i'm deeply enjoying the suit
it's ready tony get off the roof
oh trying to read the world of weapons you
gave me the best one ever pepper and now
i'm gonna kill you with it i had no idea
uh how is she not dead what you'll be
hearing from us from the strategic homeland
just call a shield there's been speculation
that i was involved in the events that occurred
the freeway and the rooftops i'm sorry
mr stark but do you honestly expect us
to believe that that was a bodyguard in
a suit it is one thing to question the
official story and another thing entirely to
make wild accusations truth is i am iron man
i love how she's just sitting there
like i got stood up by iron man got it
um listen i take full responsibility
for this i she so had a date with marvel
and uh i did not tell her like by the way
there's a thing called post credit scenes
you should stick around for them till the very end
uh but she she's already like moved on to the next
movie here but yeah that's my fault
why there's not a reaction to uh
the post credits it would have been cool
to see a reaction then i know i know i
know that's that's what i should have
told i should have told her i'm sorry
that was iron man he is iron man
well i thoroughly enjoyed that
i know this was made in like 2008 so there's some
obvious like dated stuff about it but i will say
i'm very pleasantly surprised by how i feel
like mature the plot was in comparison to
other disney action movies i know this is disney
but also marvel so also technically a little
more mature with the superhero aspects of it
i think the comic books obviously are way more
violent and mature and so i guess i was just
shocked to see a lot of uh mature elements in
this movie but as an adult i enjoyed it i thought
it was uh it was really entertaining i wish i had
tony stark's confidence like damn there's
something about that that got me a little
it's a little hot in here i love the
classic like starts out as an [__]
and then the character arc you know is blooming
throughout the whole entire film and then by
the end of it the [__] is the hero it's been
done a lot but i love the way that his character
plays it because a lot of the dialogue
was very self-aware i would say because
you would like think of certain things and you
know it would kind of you would basically think
a lot of cheesy things or you would kind of expect
him to say something based off the formula of like
other movies and dialogue and he would kind of
call it out i just thought the dialogue between
specifically between um tony stark
and pepper potts was very fun
it was very different like i don't know i would
expect them to say something cheesy and then it
was something that you know they they pretty much
turned that on its head which i thought was really
really unique a breath of fresh air for a
disney movie that typically you can kind of
you know expect certain things to happen there
were parts of the plot that were predictable but
i still enjoyed it because it seemed to be very
self-aware about it and kind of made up for it
in the dialogue i would say and a lot of
the jokes and kind of poking fun up the
genre which i think is fun and different so i i
definitely now get why iron man is a very popular
superhero i really like the characters i'm excited
to see this character continue to blossom into
a hero hopefully he keeps his snarky comments
because that's obviously part of his character and
i love it hopefully him and pepper get together i
don't know it just makes me want to watch the rest
of them i thought the military elements were very
different again not really something that i was
expecting i don't really know what i was expecting
in terms of the plot but i thought that that was
uh like again more of a mature element to have
in a movie that is considered a disney franchise
even though it is a you know formulaic sort of
situation i still really enjoyed a lot of the
cinematography in it it was different i think that
even for the time in 2008 a lot of it like didn't
look bad at all there was that scene where um the
villain was like facetiming him in the beginning
but it was before iphone so it was on his like
flip phone and like it didn't look too detailed
which i thought was great because that always
bothers me when um characters are like video
calling each other and you can tell that it looks
way too good for a video call so i mean those sort
of elements of it like the cgi i thought was
really good it definitely holds up in in that
sense in my opinion even though i don't i'm not
like an expert on cgi but nothing about the cgi
kind of pulled me out of it and was like
that looks bad you know so i thought that was
that was great it seems like this was kind of
just like it was a solid movie but it seems
like it's definitely kind of a appetizer i feel
like there's definitely more to dive into that
whole world and obviously i know there's a show
called agents of shield i haven't watched it but
i really like that that was also introduced
in this movie shield because i know that that
is a big part of the avengers right that's
something that's kind of like their own
company i guess so yeah i really enjoyed watching
this with you guys again give this video a thumbs
up if you had any sort of similar reactions
that i did or if you like my commentary on it
and again head over to the patreon
patreon.comtherealrejects if you want
to see it my full reaction don't forget to
subscribe see you guys for the next movie